Hello there, you've reached the voice mailbox of Ryan Reynolds,...
...owner of Mint Mobile.
Please leave your name, message...
...and least favorite Ryan Reynolds movie after the beep.
Oh my god!
Did I really just miss a phone call from Ryan Reynolds?
I'm not sure why you called me or who you are.
You're probably expecting a lot of people to say Green Lantern,...
...but I really liked Green Lantern...
The Proposal.
Hey, I thought you were awesome as a child actor on Little House on the Prairie.
This is hilarious!
We are also bored crazy in quarantine, so I thought I'd call you back.
Yeah, I actually haven't seen that many but I really enjoyed The Proposal.
I'm a big fan of your haircut.
I actually get my haircut very much like yours.
Going stir-crazy especially with a 14-month-old,...
...so I appreciate the call.
My least favorite Ryan Reynolds movie is probably Deadpool.
I don't have a least favorite movie of yours...
...because I have never seen any of your movies...
...but thank you for the phone service.
It's been great so far.
I will recommend you guys to my friends.
That was amazing.
I loved it.
This was great to wake up to today.
Thank you.
Okay, bye!
That was pretty cool.
Bye.